welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with this in Iran where the leaders here
face a third day of angry protests after
admitting to a deadly attack on a
commercial airliner security forces
fired tear gas at demonstrators
unconfirmed reports say live bullets
were also fired at the crowd in Tehran
protesters tore down posters of General
Kasim Soleimani killed by the u.s.
earlier this month President Trump
tweeted yesterday to the leaders of Iran
do not kill your protestors Iran says
the missile attack that downed the
Ukraine International Airlines jet
killing 176 people was a mistake
Elizabeth Palmer is in London after
Iran's government forced her and other
reporters to leave that country over the
weekend
Elizabeth why did they kick you out good
morning well when the Iranian government
asks foreign reporters to leave and it
has happened to me and many others
before it's a sign that they are
expecting public unrest and sure enough
that's exactly what they got
just hours after Iran's military
admitted shooting down the passenger
plane the protests began thousands of
mostly young people joined angry crowds
in Tehran and the protest continued last
night to social media videos showed at
least one woman shot in the leg Tehran's
police chief said he'd urged his
officers to use restraint but witnesses
say police were using live rounds just
not shooting to kill it all started with
a candlelight vigil but quickly morphed
into crowds chanting the Revolutionary
Guards are dictators and the enemy is
not America it's within one social media
post shows students refusing to walk on
large US and Israeli flags painted in
the road many of them will have seen and
shared president Trump's tweets in Farsi
calling on the Iranian leadership not to
kill the protesters on Saturday in a
stunning move general Amir Ali Hodges
adair had told the nation
it was Iran's army that had downed the
plane mistaking it for the US cruise
missile
but as pictures of the wreckage
circulated an international
investigators started their work
disbelief turned to fury not only on the
streets but everywhere Iranians were
asking if there really had been a threat
of u.s. strikes why hadn't the military
done the obvious thing and closed its
airspace to civilian planes so far today
our contacts in Tehran say things are
calm but there's no doubt public anger
is boiling government officials and the
state media are trying to deflect some
of the blame for the plane crash on to
the United States for killing Qasem
Soleimani and they say forcing Iranian
air defenses onto full alert Tony Luz
Palmer forests in London Liz thank you
very much
you